[Music]
as a freshman stepping on campus in the
year 2000
i was just a lost little puppy i wasn't
a good student
quite frankly i wasn't a good person so
i actually think that's
a big part of the reason why i connect
with some of the students here is
because
i let them in to the imperfection
um okay a first really
physical difference would be that
freshman year i came here and had blue
hair
wow that was so long ago so i met andrew
lohmann
in western heritage when i had blue hair
and we are getting married about a month
after we graduate in may
one of the key ways that my relationship
with andrew has helped me
grow is really just actively practicing
or growing in
selflessness especially in college in
general where it's very easy to focus
inward and to be this is what i need or
this is how much i need to study
just kind of realizing that it's less
the grade that you get and more the
conversation or
the knowledge you gain or the people you
meet along the way
i had kind of viewed myself as you know
like a mediocre student
but a number of different faculty
members showed confidence in me and said
hey it doesn't really matter where
you've been it matters where you're
going to go
so dr wolfram gives out swords for the
best grade in a class and i got the best
grade in both those classes and he gave
me a sword that he bought from the local
county fair
having a professor show confidence in me
that i didn't have for myself
was this really moving thing that pushed
me to actually do what i became
that relational side of things here is
so essential to the hillsdale experience
and getting to talk about these things
from augustine's confessions to boe
boethius's consolation
philosophy to platonic dialogues like
all these things
that four years ago or three years ago
my freshman self never would have really
imagined
that's i think the most vital or the
most important
the most uniquely hillsdale about all of
it
but that's what becoming an adult to
some extent is is realizing that
you have control over who you are and
what you're going to be and how you're
going to
fit within this world i wasn't ready for
it when i came
and i wasn't really ready for it when i
left but i was closer
i was a lot closer